sur cette décision et sur cette
condamnation de benjamin le dit qu'est
ce que vous en pensez est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal qu'ils étaient
condamnés pour préjudice moral vous avez
toutes des petites pancartes 1 est
toutefois l'amener là vous fabrice
trouvez ça normal ou pas oui je trouve
ça normal en fait elle est normal et
logique sur le plan juridique par l'ase
qu'est-ce qui se passe il est condamné
parce que c'est juste un problème de
droit parce qu'en fait il n'a pas
demandé l'accord du curé en fait et donc
il s'est introduit dans un lieu qui est
un lieux affectés à un usage du culte
sans demander l'accord de l'affectataire
moi c'est ça le coeur du problème est en
fait la justice se mêlent pas du point
de savoir si c'est bien mal sur le plan
moral elle dit non il ya un problème
c'est que vous êtes entré dans un lieu
vous avez fait autre chose que du culte
est au demeurant sans l'accord de
l'affectataire donc ça vous pouvez pas
le paradoxe de la décision c'est que les
autres les malades d'ailleurs c'est que
au fond elle reconnaît un préjudice
moral mais en même temps elle maintient
la vidéo ouais donc c'est un truc c'est
ça ça alors justement c'est ça
l'histoire c'est que heroes et c'est
vraiment le truc qui a le plus choqué
c'est ce qu'a dit fabrice à celle qui
les condamne les propos que tu dises
moral mais ils disent que besoin
d'enlever la vidéo c'est complètement
fou ça
cette condamnation elle est normale mais
surtout elle n'est pas assez sévère je
ne comprends pas que tik tok laisse ce
jeune homme encore s'exprimer n'enlève
pas les vidéos ce jeune homme qui grâce
à cette vidéo blasphématoire et
dégueulasse a fait 200 millions de vues
a pris des dizaines de milliers de
followers le 1er avril qui publiait
encore une vidéo un poisson d'avril dans
lequel il faisait croire à sa mère qu'il
allait faire un feu de camp avec des
corans pour moi il a blessé et manqué de
respect à des millions de personnes
alors certes le droit au blasphème ou
oui mais là il a insulté des millions de
personnes en raison de leur religion
c'est honteux et la sanction doit être
plus sévère il doit payer pour ça alors
juste floriane toi tu penses que c'est
si a buzzé cette condamnation cela
comprend pas alors c'est ça en fait le
terme c'est celui là je la comprends pas
parce que en l'occurrence s'il y avait
eu notamment je ne sais pas dégradation
du lieu de culte elle aurait été
justifié mois benjamin sa vidéo
effectivement ce qu'il a fait je
l'aurais pas fait il n'y a aucun souci
là-dessus mais tu sais ce que tu nous
avais dit aussi voilà j'ai trouvé que
c'était puéril j'ai pas bien compris où
il voulait en venir mais peu importe
le déferlement de haine qu'il a pris
derrière je ne le tolérerai jamais et ça
aussi c'est illégal il faut pas
l'oublier et ensuite il faut qu'on
m'explique parce que m vous avancez le
fait que effectivement dans un lieu de
culte le coup mais non mais bien sûr
mais vous vous l'expliqué cette décision
donc vu que moi je ne suis pas juriste
vont en l'occurrence si donc je pense
que vous pourriez vous pourriez mais
vous trouvez que c'est une entrave à la
liberté d'expression en fait moi je
comprends pas surtout cette histoire de
préjudice moral c'est à dire qu'on va
dire que puisqu'on n'a pas demandé
l'autorisation du curé il ya un
préjudice mots avec la fiq d'endroits à
l'image par exemple c'est qu'ils sont et
droits à l'image qu'en si j'utilise
votre image sans votre consentement
c'est le problème du préjudice oui mais
pas un look serait ce n'est pas l'église
enfin je veux dire c'est pas avec une
église si vous voulez ça reste un lieu
affectés à l'usagé qu'il doit que soumis
si vous voulez ce qui se passe qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que d'abord
la laïcité c'est un truc très français
quand même hein ah oui on a fait on a
fait effectivement on a des années et
des années et des siècles de problème
avec ça c'est pas un concept facile mais
le fait est que les frais d injustice
ici elle dit attends moi l'état autorise
le curé a exercé le culte chez lui ou
qu'il est quelque part les attributaires
garde et donc tout ce qui se fait dans
l'enceinte de l'établissement se fait
avec son autorisation ou ne se fait pas
c'est ça qu'elle dit en fait et on fonce
et c'est le sens a alors surgi vers
l'égout dit non cette décision est
scandaleuse et délirante pourquoi elle
est scandaleuse parce que effectivement
c'est une grave atteinte à la liberté de
d'expression et on considère que le curé
propriétaire de son église ce qui l'a
aidé l'iran mais fabrice assez délirant
sur plan du droit et ensuite il faut pas
éluder le droit pourquoi le curé il
attaquait il attaqué en disant benjamin
n'a pas répondu à mes messages
benjamin n'a pas voulu retirer sa vidéo
donc c'était l'eau du problème ils
attaquaient pour savoir si la justice
nommé les entre 9,10 s'emballe condamné
pour le fait d'être dans une église mais
pas pour la vidéo met donc fabrice tout
est fou dans l'essai benjamin s'exprimer
pour quoi que vous en pensiez voilà que
ces pannes électroniques gilbert est
qu'ils arrivent à l'heure de commenter
truc qui n'a pas lu quoi
je serais fou ça va pas recommencer ça
fait des mois que tu as des documents
plus dans le coup
c'est ça ton problème et non même si
j'étais méchant il est méchant et lui le
méchant méchant méchant toi même et en
paille ont failli milles 1 mille 1
soyons clair un vilain pas propriétaire
il est infecte à terre à kita différence
mois mais il tapait n'est pas là dessus
que je veux dire 2 le fait est que c'est
un problème de droit à l'image c'est un
atelier d'expression et parce qu'il est
rentré dans une église sans
l'autorisation détecte à terre ils
avaient pas
droit c'est votre problème après gilles
n'a pas le droit mais j'ai fini par être
arrête avec la liberté d'expression il
n'exclut pas dit c'est moi ce que c'est
la liberté d'expression alors on
n'emploie pas dé montupet les sens j'ai
oublié dossier une érosion des marges
que coûte peut-on dessus ville j'en ai
ma
question je m'engage et les territoires
la liberté d'expression c'est exprimer
des idées c'est réfléchir ses portes un
regard sur quelques jours c'est pas le
sujet le vide intersidéral
ya aucun mérite à l'origine intersidéral
yakin leurs mots la magie va d'abord
juger des bêtises moi ce qui me choque
dans cette histoire c'est qu'on apprenne
pinailler effectivement sur une petite
décision de préjudice moral avec
l'affectataire et machin moi je rejoins
guillaume là dessus ce qui est allé
aberrant c'est qu'on ait trouvé aucun
autre moyen d'attaquer ce garçon est
effectivement aujourd'hui sous prétexte
de ta liberté d'expression mais
effectivement tu dis un peu n'importe
quoi aujourd'hui et sur tik tok a gagné
un nombre de pertes de personnes
incroyablement beaucoup d'argent enfin
menacé de mort ok
pour que ça je me dis rien arrivé de
regretter qu'en mai arrêtés tirés soit
vous avez dans votre voiture à des
ternes abc l'heureux évidemment que je
me dis que c'est vrai aussi et mène donc
c'est pas grave ça crasé code entendu en
fait retirer tout
c'est pas grave elle a raison mais non
arrêté avec sa bête lorient mais surtout
interdire pouvez pas dire il n'y eut
rien arriver aujourd'hui mathieu saint
synode
seulement vous avez répondu mot pour mot
aux wem ivoiriens n'arrivent entendu
c'est pas grave tant qu'il y est rien
arrivé c'est pas grave il a aussi bien
il est rien arrivé mais pourtant il ya
sept ans aujourd'hui qu'on assassine des
gamins au nom du droit au blasphème qui
a aboli depuis peu partout
yabuli pardon pas légalement il a 18 ans
sarah
18 ans un gamin de 18 ans à 18 ans je
savais pas que gilles huit ans j'étais
en train de s attendait à l'entrée parce
que quoi mais la raison veut rien
ça reste à
camaret de vie réelle un résultat raison
à 10,81 pas amusante un gamin 13 ans 14
à 18 heures
charles aznavour à 18 ans est la
vôtre
le punch un gamin
dès 8 ans n'a jamais fait de cadeaux
arrêtez vos conneries comme à la raison
au gg moi j'en ai fait des conneries
mais j'en ai bavé j'ai jamais dit qu'on
déniche a jamais dit que j'étais un gars
chez régine vais pas la connerie cinq
fois de suite pour vous en insultant la
france entière non mais ça c'est sûr ce
qui me dérange dans cette affaire c'est
qu'au départ je me rappelle il est
l'invité fini oui il a fait une erreur
après on n'a plus concédé juste faire du
buggy voulait prendre des followers mais
voilà c'est bien peu quand on sait qu'il
a il a blessé des mines les jo voilà
voilà de toutes les religions voilà pour
une connerie et pour faire du buzz sur
le dos à l'aller les religions ça je
suis d'accord et elle adore les chats
c'est inadmissible voilà
cyril monsservin et de forêts moi je
pige pas ce truc parce que moi je pas
quoi en penser à ce que ce que
fait dans l'église mois pour le couche
catholiques pratiquants c'est moi
j'impose rien à personne pour le coup je
comprends pas qu effectivement il
quelqu'un qui se sentent obligés de
venir dans une église balancer ça sur
tik tok oui c'est quoi le but série n 7
on a tous les deux buts il a blessé des
milliers de gens
mais ça non mais c'est nul ce qui
l'affecté d'accord c'est nul un flou
rien à côté d'un minimum avec le fait
que ce soit moi j'ai envie qu'on arrête
avec ses offenses et professionnels en
permanence un 8000 blessés à wimille a
blessé des roms et ya plein de choses
mais c'est ça le débat d'idées monsieur
territoriale à venir dans une ville où
est le débat d'idées mais c'est pas la
question qu'est ce qu'il a fait était
méchant je le débat a été intéressant si
effectivement la première fois il avait
dit que c'était quelque chose contre
l'homophobie l'affairé alors ok et quand
on dit que l'islam est une religion
haineuse homophobes et c'est là on va
dire quoi on va dire encore une fois
maisons sont blessés on va pas ouvrir
débat c'est ce qui s'est passé avec la
ferme et là
tu veux dire attendez je veux dire ma
voix pour revenir je vous dire moi à
partir du moment où vous blesser
personne et une place égale des miniers
joy après moi ça me dérange je suis
désolé les vidéos contre l'islam elle me
dérange je suis désolée elle me dérange
mais voilà les vidéos en contre l'islam
avec des gens qui qui disent des choses
insupportables ça me dérange la vidéo ne
pas faire mal aux digues elle me dérange
voilà je vous le dit sa femme vers eux
et pour moi ça devrait être interdit
tout simplement alors après on va dire
la nonna 5 on peut pas rigoler sur les
religions tout ça on peut pas moi fan
dérangé désolé c'est pas drôle oui quand
on n'a pas le talent on le fait pas à
coluche avait le talent on perd des
proches de retard on se désole désolé
ça vraiment pas facile nous dire moi je
sais ce que je dis à chaque fois moi je
pense que les gens doivent être fiers de
leur religion et sierre de pratiquer
leur religion
c'est insupportable
je vous le dis c'est insupportable parce
que il ya des gens qui vont se retrouver
sur les réseaux sociaux qui vont se
retrouver devant des vidéos où ils vont
dire moi moi les vidéos sur le sur le
prophète ou vraiment ou dit des choses
inadmissibles moi je vous dire je me
peux regarder ça ébranle la fois samedi
sinon non ses rangs mais c'est noble art
et essai ça s'appelait
sa place des jo à n'avoir jamais brûlé
je laisse les gens mais ça plaît qu'il y
en a plein qui miracle est derrière
s'est persuadée d el haddad et les
communautés entières non mais moi je
suis moi je suis ultra blessé pas
combien de choses tous les jours dans ma
vie mais je sais pas c'est ça c'est ça
le fait d'être d'êtres humains vivent en
société il ya plein de choses qui me
laisse jusqu'à jusqu'à des menaces de
mort que je reçois sûr mais ma propre
messagerie pour mes propos sur l'islam
pour mes propos sur les religions en
général alors ça j'ai retiré jamais a
dit mais en plus de ça et en plus de ça
à aucun moment à aucun moment je n'ai
répondu à aucun de ces messages en
envoyant de menaces de mort jamais alors
que ça ne disait directement alors
maison pour ces professionnels qui se
lève
toi et moi c'est qu'après moi dans
l'église franchement ça tous les gens
croyants
sont que ça allait s'appeler si je suis
désolé moi j'ai ouï mais je pense qu'il
faut sur les réseaux sociaux moi je
pense qu'il faut mais depuis il faut
mettre un prix qui puisse réguler et ça
c'est plus possible mais tombe sur des
vidéos cas
alors sur les réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux
géraldine tu recommences avec le
blasphème c'est une profanation sa seat
est
ce que ça ne te choque pas c'est une
profanation vous êtes témoin moi j'ai à
vous dire si je suis d'accord avec
daniel c'est c'est moins pour moi c'est
une profanation je suis désolé mais
alors que géraldine daniel pas dire
alors la peau est un truc c'est vrai ça
sera l'interruption honorable à celle
vous verra après la narine et chats
faisant ça on verra ça serait pour ses
bas si vous avez aussi un gène vous êtes
après on verra c'est déjà ça moi je suis
d'accord avec daniel ça c'est pas
possible et que derrière on n'oblige pas
enlever la vidéo
là on est tous tombés dans le piège par
jamal aux digues il a aucune
revendication sur la religion ou
philosophiques de quoi que ce soit
benjamin il nous a même avoué ici qui
faisait ça pour le buzz pour arriver
avant le plus cher pour avoir des
followers à vendre plus cher ses photos
dénudées et la continuation de dénuder
spernot dit c'est un gamin il est assez
âgé pour faire des photos dénudées et
les vendre dans ses bras et racé à ses
cinquièmes
revendications philosophique ce jeune là
et donc lui on ne peut pas le comparer à
millas on ne peut pas le comparer à
d'autres cas de blessure mais moi quand
il a pris le coin et qu'il acquit la
[ __ ] et les vitres avaient été arrêtés
mais ça c'est
inadmissible il ya des milliers de gens
que ça va énormément choqué vous rendez
pas sur
wii fabriquer un grand homme qui est
important je
il ya quand même un point que vous
omettez sait qu'on a une société qui est
quand même cette élection la montre est
fracturée elle effraie amélioré de
l'intérieur est une vraie division voilà
l'élection est passée peu tout ça je
pense qu'il faut faire très attention à
part revendiqué le droit de blessés
professionnellement comme c'est ça je
pense qu'il faut faire très attention à
pas revendiquer le droit de blessés
blessé c'est quelque chose qui est
involontaire mais quand ces volontaires
et que c'est assumé faut faire très
attention parce que là pour le coup
quand vous commencez à blesser une
catégorie particulière de gens à raison
de leur religion à raison d'opinions
politiques à raison de leur orientation
à rien comment voulez
vous êtes quand même en danger quoi là
votre société avait quand même en danger
la série je
suis moi juste je vous dis moi je pense
qu'il faut s'adapter aussi un autre
temps que je pense que c'est ce qui
favorise un moment il ya des moments où
on voit qu'elle a en ce moment c'est
extrêmement le passif en eux et moi je
mets en compte la france d il faut
prendre des mesures qui correspondent au
climat actuel à chaque fois donc qui
correspondent aux exigences de tell tale
où tu habites en sommes à nouveau cette
fois j'étais j'en ai bavé des ronds dans
l'aigu c'est inadmissible s'est abaissée
le mois les deux je peux pas les voir
celle avec wii prend le coran pour
essayer ici c'est quoi ça fait plaisir
dans on doit retirer sa des réseaux
sociaux pour moi on doit aller retirer
on doit retirer ses vidéos purement oui
mais je ne peux pas regarder la chercher
je vais arriver à avoir des cas
difficiles mais ça vous arrive et avoir
de la pitié pour ce jeune homme et vous
embêtez pas savoir combien cherche que
ça il est content de ça il vient s'en
plaindre sur les plateaux et es salaam
et vos vidéos de mes séries
évidemment on ne pardonne on ne pardonne
aucune menace de mort mais il ya un
moment donné la sphère pour autant
rappelle qu'il n'ya aucun débat aucun
débat cherche à lui blessé le plus grand
nombre toutes les religions tu vas
blesser des gens au plus profond
d'eux-mêmes
de morts ya un moment donné
mathieu a joué un truc moi ce qui me
dérange c'est des gens qui ont blessé
des milliers de gens d'aider des
personnes qui sont croyants des
personnes allons voir voilà le le coran
voilà qu'on encensait après n'est pas
évident pourquoi pour faire du buzz et
gagnez de l'argent derrière c'est qu'on
va avoir plus de followers et maman de
ces photos plus chers derrière ça c'est
inadmissible donc si on doit faire si on
doit dire lui c'est pas possible on peut
pas faire de l'argent comme ça et on
peut pas laisser les gens il dira
d'ailleurs je vais avoir plus de gars
qui me suivent et donc tout ce que je
peux aller voir mes photos dénudées ça
c'est une invisible donc là les mecs le
régulateur edwards un régulateur qui dit
ça les fléchois lui ont l'art est
terminée il a plus droit aux réseaux
sociaux je suis désolé je m'étais basri
indigné que ça fait le buzz aussi mais
non mais
tu gagnes de l'argent sur la sur la mise
sur le sol en baissant les peines à se
priver
ses salles il a fait 200 millions de
mobiladdict à gagner de l'argent il ya
tout qui bat ana pourra dire moi je veux
faire 300 millions
des maniaques qui dit une excuse mois
dernier une énorme bêtise
encore une fois ma chérie tu dis
l'énorme bêtise car une fois excuse moi
tu dis il faut arrêter charlie hebdo
ils font pas de l'oseille sur les
réseaux pour aller vendre des photos
dénudées de time magazine à voir ça ça
magazine satirique cessèrent de ça pour
avoir plus de followers pour qu'ils
aient plus de mai car je fais des photos
dénudées qui sauf que série le creux des
séries les réseaux sociaux c'est privé
en europe et d'un privé et or étaient
des jumeaux night on truque on sait
comment ça se passe assez privé ça veut
dire que demain c'est top qui peut
décider de l'arrêter c'est pas nous
c'est pas une loi fera bien sûr oui
c'est privé donc tik tok doit l'arrêter
ça n'a rien à voir avec sambou excuse
moi oui mais non quel intérêt faire ils
gagnent des followers bien sûr vu on
parle de plus en plus d'eux c'est
important
si tu stop à un gars comme ça très bas
sa rencontre initiée soir à la raison là
dessus énormément de gens qu'à blesser
énormément de pratiquants qui a blessé
neuf que soient catholiques soient
musulmans si tu ne stoppe pas de mariana
qui va dire tu avais marre jardins de
noé qui l'a pas exactement c'est moi
j'ai 19 ans je suis un enfant finalement
les réseaux dans un village en effet
devant aller combien il a fait le tacle
est remis la drogue 600000 moi je vais
faire 800 mille je vais devant une
mosquée en slip tu rates mais j'ai 19
ans et il a raison dans son championnat
mais
[Applaudissements]
seulement seulement moi je vais je vais
redire ce que j'ai dit mais ce qui me
gêne c'est ça c'est le fait de vous avez
blesser des gens mais y'a pas de
problème et quand vous dites il ya des
gens qui sont blessés donc il faudrait
l'interdire mais alors on va adapter le
droit à chacun non mais c'est ce qui me
blesse je veux l'interdire y avait fait
je ne peux pas faire du business là
dessus parce que qu'est ce qui va se
passer si on me l'a dit la flotte mais
qui m'a dit ah ben moi je vais aller
choqué sur wat huruguen oui mais non
mais c'est pour moi mais qui à partir du
moment où ils font du business derrière
ça c'est pas possible je suis même
content l'automne l'autorisation du curé
vous avez dit fabrice vieux eddy c'est
le curé cas pas donné l'autorisation
même si le curé avait dit tu peux y
aller moi je suis quand même content
je sais pas mais sugo tequila moi ça la
met à table une même salle comme sa
tendance à se cacher
[Applaudissements]
c'est le droit le fait qu'il est filmé
dans l'église sans l'autorisation mais
quand on filme autre chose dont des
choses cultuelle dans l'église
moi je moi je peux vous dire un truc moi
ce qui me dérange le plus dans cette
affaire et je suis je pense qu'on en a
beaucoup qui vont être d'accord avec moi
c'est qu'une personne donc moi
j'aimerais lui dit qu'il a fait ça lui
ont valu mettre une petite avant et on
va pas lui fermer ces raisons on lui
aurait fermé série d'os pour vous dire
qu'il aurait pris six mois
d'interdiction de réseaux vous allez
voir ce qui va retarder la vidéo comme
il l'a fait allez voir ça va vraiment le
calme et plus grosse fumée il ya des
mecs sur twitter par exemple qui disent
qu'ils des mecs qui a des comptes un peu
un peu adapté à des comptes un peu plus
gros qu'ils disent et bandes et contre
le vaccin n'est contrôlent pas leurs
accidents voilà il ya la plaque comme il
y en a qui se sont fait arrêter et qui
se sont fait bannière de twitter les
mecs c'est normal ça alors et c'est quoi
le plus grave des mois la vérité c'est
donner son avis de nom n'est contre le
post vaccinales sur d'une heure c'est la
fusion de faisans informations mais
c'est pas c'est pas diffusion de votre
mandat aussi mais pas du tout c'est
cette année c'est une opinion tu peux
être pour ou contre le quad vaccinale
méritait pas une fausse information aux
lentilles pour moi c'est beaucoup plus
grave la vidéo de benjamin le dit que
quelqu un qui moi que je me pose des
questions sur le pass vaccinale excuse
moi je suis désolé voilà je suis désolé
mais ouais d'accord ils voulaient dessus
passer par la case de santé mais
d'opinion et n'importe quoi arrête de
dire des bêtises ça n'a rien à voir
mais qui donne une il ya un mec qui
donne son opinion un mec qui ne sous le
camion il dit je me pose des questions
sur le passé actival on lui enlève son
compte uplay hélas un mec qui fait des
les vidéos comme ça il va juste moins
d'une amende et on va laisser la vidéo
mais mais on marche sur la tête - et
regarde le compte de tous deux trains a
été suspendue en fin définitivement à
paris le compte twitter des talibans
restent ouverts ouais c'est ça et attend
il ya une espèce de truc avec les
réseaux sociaux qui est un peu curieux
maintenant il ya des accords à dernier
point si tu peux me permettre et quand
kim qui moi me pose un problème dans
tout ça il faut reconnaître qu'il ya
aussi une forme d'échec collectif il ya
un échec collectif quand un gamin ou pas
peu importe mes 18 ans quand on a besoin
de ça ah oui pour on n'a pas compris
quelque chose de vivre ensemble vous
avez raison de dire c'est pas un
problème légal c'est un problème moral
mais vous savez le ciment de la société
c'est aussi morale commune consiste
effectivement
de blesser volontairement les autres
sinon bah si on a plus de ciment zèle
dans la société quand on commence à fait
le ciment le béton social comme on le
fait la ja com quelle est la
responsabilité collective et la
république s'est dédouané
asymétrique et je vais terminer là
dessus n'oubliez jamais ça artus s'est
fait suspendre deux types tomates
n'oubliez pas
humoriste il y donc
je pense que ça sera la conclusion c'est
vrai